hey Paul when are you gonna finish what
do you mean when are you gonna finish
talking about I talking oh I'm already
finished okay good because you have a
language video to make oh that's right
what language is it today finish yeah
yeah I'm finished hello everyone welcome
to the Laing focus Channel and my name
is Paul today I'm going to talk about
the Finnish language as you probably
know Finnish is the majority language
spoken in Finland it has about 5.4
million native speakers with 4.9 million
of them living in Finland which is about
90 percent of the population of Finland
it's one of the two official languages
of Finland along with Swedish which is
spoken by about 5% of the population and
there are also finished speaking
minorities across the border in Russia
in Norway and in Sweden you may have
seen my video on the North Germanic
languages it's this one right here and
you might remember that I specifically
excluded Finnish from that video that's
because even though Finland is a Nordic
country with Geographic and historical
connections to Scandinavia the Finnish
language is not a North Germanic
language in fact it's not even an
indo-european language it is part of the
Finnick language group which is a branch
of the Uralic language family other
members of the finnick group are
estonian karelian ludecke veps ingrian
vote ik and livonian but finnish is the
most widely spoken language in the
finnick language group all the finnic
languages developed from proto Finnick
which was spoken around 3,000 years ago
the first stage was early proto Finnick
then during the middle proto fennec
period some changes took place in that
language and it split into two proto
Samak the ancestor of the Samak
languages and late proto Finnick which
ultimately became the most recent
ancestor of all the finnic languages
it's worth noting that Finnish contains
a significant number of Germanic
loanwords some of them which are clearly
ancient in origin for example Kooning us
which means king - orally which means
chair and it comes from the same root as
stool and go loop which means school
from words like these we can see that
the ancient Finns had extensive contact
with Germanic peoples late proto Finnick
diverged into three dialects Eastern
proto fennec northern proto Finnick and
southern proto Finnick these three
dialects of
proto Finnick mixed with each other and
the resulting mixes of influences
developed into the dialects that make up
the Finnish language around the 12th
century and 13th century see II Sweden
conquered Finland and made it a province
of their country and for the next few
hundred years Swedish was the language
of administration and during this time
middle Low German was the lingua franca
of Commerce in the area and Latin was
the language of religion Swedish and
middle low German left an additional
Germanic influence on Finnish which
during that time was strictly a language
of daily communication Finnish did not
really become a written language until
the 16th century when a Finnish bishop
named Mikhail
Agricola created the first comprehensive
writing system for the language he based
that system on the orthography of German
Swedish and Latin and it still forms the
basis of the finished writing system
today although there have been changes
since then in 1809 Russia seized Finland
from Sweden in a war and made it an
autonomous state as part of the Russian
Empire the official language and the
language of the elite remained Swedish
but Finnish national feeling and a
desire to make the Finnish language
dominant began to increase in 1835 these
feelings were amplified by the
publication of Kalevala a work of epic
poetry written by alias loon wrote with
stories from Karelian and finnish
folklore and mythology
Ludendorff also played an important role
in the development of standard Finnish
in 1863 Finnish became an official
language in Finland alongside the
Swedish language and they both remain
official languages today and with a new
sense of national identity emerging
Finland eventually gained independence
from Russia in 1917 before standard
Finnish was created the Finnish language
consisted of a number of dialects that
could be roughly divided into eastern
and western dialects the Western
dialects are the ones upon which
standard Finnish was largely based from
what I understand these days the
dialects mostly consist of differences
in accent but outside of Finland there
are a few interesting dialects that are
officially considered to be different
languages even though they are
intelligible with standard Finnish this
includes the Karelian language in Russia
maeín ki le which is spoken by a Finnish
minority in Sweden and Cavan which is
spoken by a minority in Norway so what
is the Finnish language like well it
shares some features with the other
members of the finnick language group
some of those features are no
grammatical gender there was no
distinction between masculine feminine
or neuter not even in the personal
pronouns Han means both he and she and
interestingly Finland was one of the
first countries to grant women the right
to vote and it was one of the first to
have a female president so maybe gender
equality is just built into the language
and way of thinking hey you never know
next no articles articles are the words
like ah or the in English English
speakers often wonder how you can
communicate without those articles but
the context usually provides enough
meaning that you don't actually need the
articles next finish has some
prepositions in English those are words
showing location or relationship like -
or at or on but finish has many more
post positions these are similar to
prepositions in function but they come
after the word that they add meaning to
rather than before here's an example
sentence with the post position durian
couple in keskküla the sentence means
the market is in the center of town tori
means market own is similar to is Cal
Pune is town the end at the end of Cal
Poly is the genitive case showing
possession and then after Cal booming we
have cask Ella which is the post
position which means in the middle so
it's a post position because it comes
after the now cow pony next
lots of grammatical cases 15 to be
precise that means the nouns personal
pronouns and adjectives have 15
different forms depending on their
function in the sentence we can't look
at all 15 right now but let's look at an
example finish has the accusative case
which marks a direct object and that's
common in lots of languages it can be
shown with an N at the end of the word
or it can be shown with nothing just
left blank at the end of the word but
there is also something called the
partitive case this also marks a direct
object if the object is only part of a
whole or if the action is incomplete or
if the action is negative just Cocola
this sentence means
will you eat the fish should means you
eat KO is a question marker kala is fish
and the end at the end of kala is the
accusative case showing that the action
will be completed and that the whole
fish will be eaten Cheska kala means do
you eat fish so again should is you eat
cook it's the question marker kala is
fish and the AH at the end of kala is
the positive case which shows that
there's no
completed action there's no completed
action because there's no specific fish
being eaten this is just a general
question next you may have noticed in
the above example sentences that the
present tense and future tense are the
same that's right in Finnish there is no
future tense but the future can be
indicated in a couple of ways when you
see a present tense verb with an
accusative case object like this that
indicates the future because it shows
that the action will be complete at some
point when you see a present tense verb
with the partitive case like this that
indicates present tense because the
action is not a completed action so it
must be happening now the future can
also be clarified with a time expression
here's an example demonstrating that
there is no future tense in Finnish
fluent this means I read learn woman
this means I will read tomorrow whoo Oh
men that means tomorrow and that time
expression is what indicates that this
action will take place in the future
next there are a lot of long words and
finish because of agglutination and
because of compound words finishes an
agglutinative language meaning that
words can be formed by attaching
together pieces that add meaning to the
word without those pieces changing you
just attach them together in English we
might use separate words like
conjunctions and prepositions
but in Finnish special endings can be
added to a word stem here's an example
starting with the word for house boys so
Nicki and a few additional features are
finished number one the main stress
always goes on the first syllable of the
word number two there was no equivalent
of the verb to have in Finnish number
three Finnish has negative verb
conjugations that means that instead of
using a negation word like not it has an
entirely different form of the verb to
show that it's negative Finnish is
clearly a very interesting language that
might be quite different from the
languages that you're used to speaking
and learning but it's finished as hard
to learn as people say it is well I
can't tell you from personal experience
but it seems to me that if you've never
learned a language from the finnick
group or from the Uralic language family
before then you'll probably have to bend
your mind a little bit to understand how
that language works and that'll probably
take more focus and effort than learning
a language that's more similar to your
own but as is always the case your
passion
for any language a culture will carry
you through the challenges of learning
that language so if you're fascinated by
Finnish you really should go for it okay
the question of the day for Finnish
speakers how noticeable are the Finnish
dialects today can you tell where a
Finnish speaker is from just by hearing
them speak and a different question for
people who studied Finnish how
challenging is finished to learn did you
find it quite tough or did you just find
it different let us know in the comments
down below thanks again to all my
patreon supporters for your continued
support and everyone else thank you for
watching and have a nice day
[Music]